I can understand why it might feel scary
to talk to people because back in the
day when we lived in tribes if you
didn't get on with your fellow tribe
members if they excommunicated you to
the Jungle or wherever you were you
can't eat you can't can't you can't
survive without them you can't look
after your children so when people say
public speaking is scarier than death
and all of that stuff I think that
applies to all speaking like it I can
see how it can get so distorted in your
head that if I speak to this person they
reject me M it's going to feel like
death you know so I think yeah shyness
is kind of normal way more normal than
we think it is or anxiety around
speaking in some way I'm kind of using
those terms
interchangeably uh that's that's that's
really normal and yeah it is also a
superpower